in this episode i traveled throughout
uganda to find out what was rated by the
times magazine is one of the worst
hundred ideas of a century the ugandan
space program to accidentally find a
homemade spaceship
hey i'm dan mays i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
[Music]
this story dates back to three years ago
when at a friend's party where he told
me about an apparent time magazine
article that was dedicated to the worst
hundred ideas of the century
where one of those ideas was a secretive
supposed space program based mainly in
uganda
[Music]
between now and then i have been
obsessed with finding out the truth like
where is it now where is this hidden
african space village it's time to
complete this idea that i wrote down
three years ago in los angeles find the
missing ugandan space program
so i packed all my gear
i booked a ticket to kampala which is
the capital of uganda and met my friend
ryan there the one that told me about
the story three years ago who just flew
in from ale it was only fair we
conquered this mission together
okay so we are currently situated in
kampala in the 1970s when president
idiamin came into power he announced an
impossibly optimistic human spaceflight
program that allegedly did training on
an obstacle course made out of tires and
would roll space cadets downhills in
barrels to recreate g-force furthermore
amin claimed to have witnessed ufo
activities over lake victoria which is
this massive body of water here it's so
large that he was also convinced it was
the ocean however this space program
didn't develop any astronauts or get
into space but who knows maybe they did
it was all kept very secretive and no
media source to this day has uncovered
where this training ground was situated
or if it even existed with further
research we found out that there's a man
who apparently built a rocket ship in
his mother's backyard around 10 years
ago where the location is also unknown
in this video we aim to uncover what
really went down and figure out where
the space program is now currently in
2022 so on day one ryan and i decided to
dress up as news reporters from a fake
news channel called space news network
channel 103 and interview locals on the
streets of kampala
okay we are waiting for our border
border which is literally called the
border border because it's the fastest
way to get around the city from border
to border trying to wave one down
[Applause]
okay we have just arrived at the
marketplace and we're about to begin the
interviews
ryan and i have come to the naked cereal
market which is in the heart of kampala
and disguised as news anchors to find
out more about the ugandan space program
let's see how this goes what space
channel are we again space news network
you're rolling
we are space news network
channel 103 coming to you live from
nakasiro
i think we should go deep bro
can you tell me more about the ugandan
space program i i don't get to the town
space
what
i know they are very expensive but you
know it happened i think so
okay that's positive
i have never heard about that
you mean you mean the weather the
spaceships
spaceships
i
have heard a little bit about it
yes i've heard about it i have a friend
aries structure and a historian i can
take it to him
seems like we've got a lead the
information that i've gathered today is
that not many people know about the
space program but some people seem to
know about it and we've got the lead of
a local historian who we're going to
find out more about so seems like it's
here somewhere
we just need to find our way
[Music]
i'm dan dan you're good to meet you
we in with the legit it's time to get
some real information
so i guess the first question is
is
if you could contextualize what the
ugandan space program means the uganda
space program
did not exist
okay
thank you so much that that was yeah
thank you so much for your time i really
appreciate it
you do most welcome okay cool that was
quick
yeah
who knows she may be there
one percent i'll let you know if we find
the space program with all the
astronauts
i want
i want to join them
yeah it seems like there's a one percent
chance that the space program exists one
percent is good enough we'll continue
our mission
we then met with kalia guerra a famous
journalist and researcher at the
macarreria university of technology who
in 2009 was a part of building a private
space program in uganda so you you were
part of a space program i was well i
guess i just took the type ahead of
research
upgrades all this hype and everything
a website written as the
africanspacemission.com
the the political correct minorities so
why not become the first black african
in space and uh
once again all things uganda that's as
far as it got
but we are getting closer
to uncovering the real story
one one step at a time exactly
after this we headed to the local
library to uncover archives from the
first ever apparent space program which
seems to be super secretive however here
we uncovered our best lead yet
we are headed to an area where we've
been tipped off where apparently the
astronauts were trained during the
ugandan space program hi sorry yeah
we're about to meet major
who will hopefully verify the story so
that we can get to the end of this
mystery was there really a ugandan space
program
hello good to meet you
strictly restricted area
do you understand that yeah okay
thank you okay
so this is uh these are the remnants of
the space program training area this
year yes but it just looks like a few
tires not the the weather were all over
this place hundreds of people
coming here
roll
yeah
i heard stories about that i just didn't
know if it was true
are you okay
if there are hundreds of people training
here why did nobody know about
it was very secretive but the times
magazine found out about it
they did
they didn't find out they found about it
so what now there is one young man yeah
called christensen who's trying to hide
at his own personal space
how do i find kristen samban i can give
you the number
amazing yeah but all this
was open nothing maybe not
but hey you're right maybe not
thank you man you know thanks again it's
been a great pleasure you guys have
walked out of here because yeah i get
that we don't remember
[Music]
finding out that the space program did
indeed exist was a huge win on its own
we're gonna come to you now
all right no problem i'm waiting for you
to get into contact with a local
self-proclaimed astronaut who's
apparently building his own spaceships
now this is what you call a real cherry
on the top
chris interview
so what can you tell me about the
ugandan space program it consists of
ugandans so it does exist
yeah it does exist all these equipments
are built under that
all the space related projects were
executed they were executed under that
chris built a rocket ship in his mom's
backyard that is going to fly 80 000
feet above sea level called the african
skyhawk and has created many other
devices to extract research from space
but it is privately owned yes would you
as chris then call yourself a new age
astronaut yes
that's a big yes because we believe in
designing technologies to do work for us
since uganda existed
we were the first guys to execute
something
space related it it started its
existence in 2008
yeah your story is fascinating and it's
inspiring and i'm honored to be sitting
here and i wanted to thank you for that
oh you're very welcome
[Laughter]
spending three days in uganda uncovering
the story reminded me why i make phones
being afforded the opportunity to travel
to such unfathomable places meeting
geniuses going against all odds i am
truly grateful and thank you uganda for
having us
we will definitely be back soon
i've just returned from uganda and had a
lot of time on the plane to process the
sheer amount of rich stories we
uncovered there
yes i love you yes yes yes firstly this
story doesn't just exist in uganda but
exists throughout africa like here in
south africa we've got an african space
hero named sierra boulela who started
making his own jet fuel in his mother's
kitchen in her township house and later
got an asteroid named after him by nasa
these incredible stories about african
space travel have inspired me to create
my first ever feature-length film along
with warner brothers discovery which
will start shooting later this year so
yeah this video is just a slice of the
bigger picture of what's to come and
other than that don't forget you're
awesome bro and i'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you